in deutschland ist es ein echtes
tabuthema darüber zu sprechen was man
verdient und genau deshalb gehen wir
halt mal auf die straße und fragen
einfach diese provokante frage was
verdienst du ich freue mich schon auf
die antworten los geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie viel verdienst du
das ist wirklich eine ziemliche und
typische verlage da muss ich jetzt erst
mal kurz überlegen ob ich da doch so
geradeaus reagiere das verdienst du
[Gelächter]
es ist schwer zu sagen das schwankt
immer sehr nach dir je nachdem wie viel
ich arbeite aber
zwischen so ein und 2000 euro im monat
was verdienen die ich für wenig genug
und ausreichend doch so viel dass ich
happy bilden und wirklichkeit hin berlin
was verdienst du
verdiene immer unterschiedlich viel geld
aber auch wertschätzung dass wir nicht
schön was verdienen sie
okay aber beantworte ich gerne also
mittlerweile genug
und wenn man von netto reden dann sind
lasst mich nachdenken 2000 euro ist zwar
nicht die welt aber mir reicht
das ist tatsächlich bei mir
unterschiedlich weil ich nicht also ich
habe einen job aber
ich bekomme noch zusätzliche leistung
also genau deswegen variiert das bei mir
tatsächlich ich verdiene gemäss tv l 13
ich bin wissenschaftler mitarbeiter und
gibt es tarifverträge
wie viel verdienst
moment gar kein geld willst du denn gar
kein job wie
überlebst du denn ich kriege ein
bisschen support von meiner familie und
hat noch einiges angespartes vom
arbeiten wie viel verdienst du
ich habe tatsächlich heute meinen job
gekündigt oder heute war mein erster
arbeitstag
und war die ganze zeit lang im vertrieb
tätig und habe das ist ja sehr gut
verdient auch da ich software verkauft
habe und deswegen gibt es die nächsten
zwei drei monate frei von meinem
ersparten vom letzten jahr
wie viel verdienen sie
das ist unregelmäßig weil ich
selbstständig bin
ja
ich weiß gar nicht runter gebrochen ist
auf 10.000 im jahr vielleicht ist ganz
unterschiedlich es geht von 17 euro bis
1800 die stunde
1000 aktuelle stunde dann respekt man
also es ist variiert das ist nicht so
die höchste summe die kommt halt sehr
selten vor aber das kann passieren
sondern also dass in der spanne von 17
bis 100 bis fast 1800 ist durchaus
möglich ich rede jetzt von einem
einzelbeispiel sonne aber ich sag mal so
grundlegend jetzt ausschnitte von 17 bis
80 euro so das ist so der schnitt so
dass er so meine spannendes und
letztendlich nach dem was ich mache
während wir hier über gehälter reden
oder auch nicht reden denn es ist ja
immer noch ein tabuthema in deutschland
fragt ihr euch bestimmt was ist denn
eigentlich ein gutes gehalt in
deutschland und wie viel verdienen die
leute eigentlich in deutschland dazu
habe ich euch mal ein paar zahlen
mitgebracht das durchschnittsgehalt in
deutschland liegt ungefähr bei 3000 euro
brutto brutto heißt man zieht dann noch
steuern und versicherungen zum beispiel
krankenversicherung ab und dann hat man
das nettogehalt übrig und das ist das
geld was man dann tatsächlich am ende
des monats hat das durchschnittliche
netto gehalt beträgt in deutschland
circa
2000 euro und der mindestlohn in
deutschland der beträgt 9 euro 50 pro
stunde
jetzt variieren die gehälter allerdings
sehr stark je nachdem in welcher branche
man arbeitet wenn man zum beispiel
kellnert oder ein verkäufer ist in einem
supermarkt dann verdient man so zwischen
1800 bis 2000 euro im monat wenn man
aber zum beispiel ein ingenieur oder
arzt oder ärztin dann kann das auch
schon schnell über 5000 euro sein ihr
seht hier gibt es eine riesige spanne
warum ist diese frage ein tabu in
deutschland warum stellt man nicht gerne
diese frage ich glaube dass deutschland
gesellschaftlich sehr ein sehr sozialer
staat ist und für manche leute viel geld
haben
nichts ist womit man angeben sollte
sondern es geht darum dass man dass alle
das ist gleich verteilt ist vielleicht
ist das nicht ein thema
web sicherheit in der türkei wo ich
herkomme sprechen leute viele bargeld
finde ich auch nicht gut ist auch zuviel
vergleichen sich zu vergleichen sich
einzuordnen ist man irgendwie ist man
besser schlechter als der andere dran
ich habe kein problem damit aber in der
öffentlichkeit habe ich ein problem
damit ja schwierig schwierig zu
beantworten ja das ist erstaunlich
eigentlich ist gibt
glaube ich die vorbehalte dass man dann
komisch beäugt wird weil man entweder
weiß ich nicht zu viel oder zu wenig
gemessen daran was man eigentlich tut
verdient also ich glaube das ist einfach
so historisch gewachsen dass das ein
bisschen tabuisierten frei geworden ist
aber eigentlich finde es gut dass nur
der award transparent redet also ich bin
auch ein bisschen hin- und hergerissen
geld ist ja generell so ein bisschen
immer ein tabuthema aber manchmal wollen
die leute nicht so richtig sagen wie
viel sie eigentlich haben weil sie sonst
immer genau sein und
deshalb reden leute wahrscheinlich nicht
gelten sie wirklich verdienen um danach
nicht rechtfertigen zu müssen wieso sie
so mit ihrem geld haushalten wie sie
damit haushalten das ist ja auch
arbeitgeber gewollt weil der arbeitgeber
will nicht dass sich die arbeitnehmer
untereinander unterhalten und
austauschen weil jeder hat vielleicht
einen anderen stundenlohn und wenn die
sich dann austauschen und sehen die
arbeiten das gleiche und verdiene aber
unterschiedlich deshalb revolte oder
ähnlich wie auch mehr und so deswegen
ist es eigentlich nur vom arbeitgeber
geworden dass arbeitnehmer sich
untereinander unterhalten okay der eine
sagt vielleicht ich rede nicht mit dem
weil dann das night erzeugt so das ist
schon richtig es gibt überall neider und
die können
sie sagen dann auch so ist er voll blöd
der verdient mehr und lala und sehen
vielleicht auch nicht das komplette
das komplette spektrum was derjenige zum
beispiel übernimmt warum wir vielleicht
auch mehr verdient sondern aber wenn es
genau das gleiche ist ist es gut sich
auszutauschen und ja warum ist es dann
kam in deutschland darüber zu reden
warum kann ich dir gar nicht so genau
sagen das ist so ist sich schon sagen
ich will kann jetzt hat google zeichnet
sondern es ist einfach nicht freundlich
quasi jeden auf die nase zu binden was
man verdient weil die
gehaltsunterschiede in deutschland auch
schon durchaus hoch sein können wir
haben die geschirre zwischen arm und
reich wächst in deutschland und nicht
jeder beruf wird adäquat bezahlt auch
wir kennen das in sozialen berufen
werden schlecht bezahlen andere berufe
wie gehabt sind werden sehr gut bezahlt
und von daher ist er respektvoll
zurückhaltend quasi nicht im anderen
unbedingt seine gehaltshöhe seien
geheilt check für die nase zu halten und
das war auch sagen muss ist geheilt ist
ja auch nicht alles sondern für die
menschen in deutschland sozusagen
verdienen geld mit vermögen mit häusern
mit einkommen mit erbschaften ja und
mögen vielleicht wenig verdienen haben
wir viel geld auf dem konto und von
daher ist es eine schwierige dimension
was verdiene ich die frage müsste
eigentlich lauten was habe ich für ein
vermögender und was sozusagen ja was bin
ich in der lage zu leisten und ich
glaube deswegen sind menschen in
deutschland auch geneigt diese frage
erst mal auszuweichen und ehren im
engeren wohlwollende freundeskreis das
dann konkret zu diskutieren
[Musik]
übrigens wir möchten euch einladen ein
mitglied zu werden von easy german damit
unterstützt ihr unsere arbeit und ihr
unterstützt auch gleichzeitig euer
deutsch lernen ihr könnt dann nämlich
interaktive übungen zu allen videos
machen und auch zu diesem video könnt
ihr dann die vokabeln lernen und die
besonderen ausdrücke die heute in dieser
episode hört
denken sie dass die bezahlung
angemessen ist für das was sie leisten
müssen
gerade momentan sehr viel arbeit und das
könnte glaube ich dementsprechend und
das bisschen mehr sein doch vom gefühl
her und war deine bezahlung an gemessen
an dem was du leisten musste wenn
überhaupt dann war es zu viel
das ist teil lud der aussage prima sind
sie zufrieden mit dem was ich verdiene
ich bin zufrieden weil ich ein
genügsamer mensch bin also das ist
tatsächlich so her also ich habe früher
schon mal mehr verdient nicht viel mehr
aber ein bisschen mehr und da war ich
tatsächlich unzufriedener weil mir die
arbeit keinen spaß gemacht hat das ist
eigentlich war ja und jetzt also ich sag
mal ich arbeite in einem kiosk
ganz einfach als verkäufer und es gibt
mir mehr als vorher mal also vorher
hatte ich mehr stress in dem buch ich
denke der mindestlohn sollte zum
beispiel erhöht werden ich denke
die musik die ich mache wenn ich auflege
da kann sich auch ein bisschen mehr geld
viel verdienen
ja es ist in ordnung aber es ist noch
luft nach oben
ja ich bin zufrieden dabei ist es immer
noch da oben
bist du zufrieden damit was du verdienst
ja weil der großteil meines lebens
der der macht mich so glücklich über
meine freunde meine familie mein mindset
so wie ich denke dass das andere
nebenbei läuft also hauptsache es reicht
vielleicht um das eine oder andere sich
zu finanzieren aber ich glaube das
wichtigste ist dass man zufrieden mit
seinem leben ist und geld ist nicht das
leben der alltag freunde familie ist für
mich wichtig und das ist
mir absolut das ist sehr schön jetzt
interessiert uns mal was janisch
verdient ja ich verdiene genug aber mich
interessiert am meisten was davon übrig
bleibt für meinen taschen weil das gebe
ich dann wirklich mit freude aus für
neue gitarren oder neue verstärker oder
neue
unterrichtsstunden ja jetzt bin ich
gespannt was ihr sagt ist das in eurem
land auch tabu über gehälter zu sprechen
redet ihr mit euren freunden darüber was
ihr verdient das interessiert uns
schreibt uns mal bitte einen kommentar
und natürlich könnt ihr auch mit uns
darüber diskutieren wenn ihr einen pajun
mitglied werdet bei uns dann diskutieren
wir zusammen darüber weiter in unserem
forum und auch in unserem chat und wir
freuen uns wenn ihr ein mitglied werde
damit helfen wir uns nämlich unsere
gehalt zu finanzieren denn tatsächlich
finanziert sich unser projekt fast
ausschließlich über eure spenden und das
freut uns sehr hier unten verschicken
wir euch den link zu unserer petition
mitgliedschaft danke fürs zu sehen und
danke dass du so toll moderiert hatte
[Musik]